[Music]
so this is joint work with lots of
lovely people and so so a lot of the
talks in this workshop are about
continuous optimization problems and
using hyperbolic palm we also saw that
this is not one of them that we are
going to solve a discrete optimization
problem so things of this form so you
have a function and subsets of size K of
n elements and you want to maximize this
this is a very generic one
but polynomials are going to show up and
the vapor mules are going to show up our
you can't you should think of this
function as encoding the coefficients of
a polynomial and we are going to use
this power mule and its properties to
basically do this discrete optimization
so just to make sure we are all on the
same page for for each subset of size K
you just form a monomial out of the N
variables and the value of the function
just gives you the coefficient of those
monomial in the poem so so there is
there is one very specific example of
discrete optimization that's going to
show up a lot in this talk and that's
when this function is given by a
determinant so think of n vectors that
are in some euclidean space and you're
assigning to every subset of size K of
them the value the determinant of or the
volume spanned by the by the vectors in
that subset squared so as many people
here probably know these are the
coefficients of a very useful form you
know it's a determinant upon you know so
so basically the associated Paul mule to
this discrete function is easy to
compute
so if you form the gram matrix of these
vectors this is an N by n matrix wherein
entry IJ basically you write down the I
dot VJ what you're what you're basically
trying to compute when when trying to
compute G mu is the sum of K by K minors
of of this matrix every K by K minor
basically its determinant gives you the
volume squared of the corresponding
vectors in that subset and you're trying
to compute the sum of the K by K minors
which is the elementary symmetric
formula applied to the eigenvalues of
the same piece so the panel in this case
is easy to compute but can we use that
power to do discrete optimization so so
this was done by niccolò in 2014 so what
he showed was that we can optimize we
can find a subset of size K that
maximizes this determinant up to a
factor of 2 to the K and this is also
known to be the best approximation
possible assuming complexity theory
assumptions so you might think that this
is actually a terrible approximation
factor but but you should think of the
determinant as like a degree ke function
and so this is this is the right sort of
approximation any questions
okay so so what I'm going to show you is
next is basically a generalization of
this to two arbitrary functions whenever
the corresponding polynomial has a
certain property so if you want to find
the maximum coefficient of this
polynomial here is an integer program
you can write that that solves the
problem for you
you just plug in zero one numbers for
the variables in the column you'll and
you make sure that exactly K of these
variables are 1 and and this gives you
the value of the poem you at this point
gives you the the coefficient of that K
values so as as is usual in in
approximation algorithms we were just
going to relax this to to a non integer
program so we're just going to drop the
constraint that these are 0 1 variables
instead we're just going to make sure
that these are positive numbers this is
essentially what Nikolov ah has also
done and now the question is is this
relaxation a good approximation and more
fundamentally can we actually solve this
relaxation because the objective here is
the polynomial there is it's not obvious
immediately that we can optimize this
not necessarily it's not gonna I mean
you can put in more constraints if you
want but it's not gonna be necessary so
all right so the first question is is
this an is this approximation good and
when is it good what what properties of
the polymer implies that this is a good
approximation and the answer is that you
don't actually need much for this to be
a good approximation no matter what the
pong wheel is the solution to this
relaxation is always a good
approximation this is very easy to see
basically what you can do is you can
solve this relaxed problem you get a
bunch of the eyes and then you can
sample a set of size K with probability
proportional to the product of the eyes
so if you do this randomized algorithm
the expected value of MU at the set that
you get is going to be basically the
value of the palm Y divided by the
normalizing constant in this
proportionality normalizing constant in
this proportionality is just the
elementary symmetric form you'll apply
that to the eyes so so so basically this
is the this is the value that you try to
optimize from the relaxation and this
divided by the elementary symmetric
polynomial is what you're gonna get out
of this algorithm so so the
approximation factor is bounded by how
much this can be okay and the elementary
symmetric Palmilla love a bunch of
variables that sum up to K
it's going to be at most e to the K so
an easy way to see this is that the
elementary symmetric polynomial is
actually a lot concave function it is
hyperbolic for example and and it is
also symmetric with respect to the
variable Z I so it's Maximizer is going
to be a multiple of the old ones okay so
this is maximized so EK is maximized
basically Zi is equal to K over and for
Zi is equal to K or K over N ek is
basically this K over N divided to the
power K times and choose K and you can
use any inequality that you want like
the fact that the n choose K can be
bounded from above by an e over K times
K + u over K to the power K and then you
get there are multiple other ways of
getting this you can use the fact that
these are the elementary symmetric
polynomials are ultra low concave in
terms of K and so on so ok so e to the K
is what you get
using complexity theory assumptions we
know that at least for the determinant
case you can't get anything better than
this at least up to a constant factor in
front of K so the approximation is
always good so the question is now can
we actually compute this the solution to
this relaxation and and you know we are
trying to solve some optimization
problem some continuous optimization
problem now and obviously if you have
some form of convexity we can solve it
otherwise we probably can't hope for
that precision
so in particular what we need is at
least quasi concavity of this palm we
need the level sets of this formula to
be convex that implies that for example
the the optimizer is unique and if you
if you do like gradient descent or
something like that then you will
converge to it so so quasi concavity is
just this fact that when you plot the
when you basically take the contour plot
of your polynomial so these are the
level sets of your palm LG equals 1 G
equals to G equals 3 and so on
above sets of these sets are just convex
shapes well you know it's a it's a
folklore fact that quasi concavity for
homogeneous things is the same as low
concavity is the same as all sorts of
other concavity so we can hope to do
this optimization exactly when our palm
oil is low kanji so so when we are
dealing with the la concave formula we
can solve this relaxation and it will
give us a good approximation and that's
maybe the end of the story there is one
question I haven't answered yet which is
how do we even compute this problem so
in the determinant case I I showed you
that you can compute this formula by
forming that gram matrix and computing
the eigenvalues and the elementary
symmetric polynomials and so on but in
general because we are only dealing with
the case where the polynomial is La
concave we can approximately compute the
palm you yeah even if we only have an
Oracle that computes mu for us
so this is because you can you can
basically sample a set s with
probability proportional to the term
corresponding to s in the polynomial so
this is this is a research result with
we always kind and Cynthia and then you
can use all sorts of classic reductions
from approximate counting to sampling to
compute the partition function of the
sample which is the pound and then you
might ask okay so this gives us an
approximate solution but approximate
evaluation of a function is is enough
for for optimization at least in this
case this is all very easy and simple
but but notice that what we did was we
try to basically solve the discrete
optimization problem and we do that we
reduce that basically to accounting
problem
so basically computation of an
expectation and then we basically
substituted this expectation with a
surrogate which which was an approximate
surrogate that was con la concave and
and then we basically have optimized
this this surrogate instead of the
original optimization so then the
question is now okay so when we are
dealing with a discrete function whose
formula is LA concave this all works but
can you go beyond this so so what I'm
going to show you is is a special case
there is there are there are things more
general than this that you can view but
for simplicity we are going to focus on
and what on this this specific problem
think of constrained optimization now
okay so instead of optimizing this new
function over all sets of size K we are
given a family of all of these subsets
and we want to maximize over this family
so so if you if you think of basically
the indicator function of this family as
the function nu which Maps sets in the
family to one and sets outside of the
family to 0 then this optimization
problem is basically equivalent to
maximizing the product of new life
so so the the unfortunate thing is even
if mu and nu both satisfy what we
required before which was law concavity
of the corresponding column you know
this product doesn't necessarily have
this property so we can't just take a mu
and nu which are la concave and hope
that the same method works for MU at
times but but we can still basically try
to apply the same framework of going
from this discrete optimization to an to
computing an approximate surrogate of
the partition function or the policy and
that's what we're going to do for the
rest of the time so so our goal now is
to basically compute an approximation to
to the palm corresponding to MU times nu
and then hopefully that that
approximation will turn out to be la
concave in the variables of this ball so
so a little bit of history of this so
Mohit and and Nikolov basically did this
when knew the the constrain function was
coming from a partition mate right and
mu the Palmilla for MU was satisfied
some stronger form of la concavity real
stability so this was based on earlier
results of Corvettes then then together
with Shayan we showed that you can still
get the same sort of surrogate
approximation when when the palm heels
from you and knew both satisfy a
stronger form of a concavity Cockrell
stability and and Strasse can vishna we
also obtained a similar independent
result but what I want to show you today
is that you don't need real stability
when when mu and nu they're polymers are
both la concave you still get the same
sort of approximate sorry
and this approximate surrogate is going
to end up being lucky so so so this is
the task that we want to do right so
this is this is an expectation with
variables T I've replaced the variables
to TI's so so we want to sum over all
subsets as mu of s times mu of s times
the product of T is so at the end of the
day if we get a surrogate for this which
is LOC concave in terms of T is we can
do exactly the same thing that we did
before we can optimize over T is and
then the end result is going to be a
good approximation so so so to get this
surrogate approximation we have to do
some tricks so first of all we are going
to we are going to form basically the
complement of this new constraint set so
so new was basically an indicator
function over subsets of size K you can
form this complement function which maps
which takes basically the complement of
all of the sets indicated by you so
these are subsets of size n minus K and
so a trivial fact is that not not so
trivial if you don't know what matrix
are but so basically when when new has
this lock on cavity property the sets
defined by new form the basis of a
Maitre and now the the sets defined by
new complement also form the basis of a
mate or the duo may Troy so so when new
has this lock on cavity property the new
complement also has this lock on cavity
problems so ano for four new complement
is like a key
and now we can form this this partition
function that we are desperate to to
approximate using this the Palmilla for
new compliment okay so let me let me
parse this for you so so so don't forget
about the the the this denominator and
and these divisions by T is for now okay
so what I'm going what I'm doing is I'm
multiplying the palm here from you by
the palm you'll for new compliment and
I'm applying a bunch of differential
operators to it so so in this
differential operator for for each
variable I have basically partial y plus
partial Z either Y is the variable
occurring in Miu and Zi is the variable
occurring in new complements so if you
want to compute the right-hand side of
this what you can do is you can for from
each each one of these parentheses you
have to choose either partial Y I or
partial Z I and for any choice that you
make you can just expand this out and
see what what's the number that we get
and the result is just the sum of all of
all of these numbers now these choices
have a meaning basically the set s is
going to be
so for every choice of of partial y is
versus partials the eyes that you take I
can form this set s which is the set of
partial Y eyes that the set of indices
at which I could I took partial Y I
right so now now when you expand this
out the partial Y eyes are only applied
to G mu so so when when the when
basically so now you're basically
applying this operator
so so this first part of the operator is
applying so this is the sum over all
this this is exactly the same expression
as on the right hand side so so when you
apply this operator to G mu times G new
the the partial by eyes get absorbed by
G mu okay and what you get out of this
is this is the sum whereas
so this expression is going to be mu of
s because you're taking derivatives with
respect to the variables Y eyes and this
is going to end up being universe this
is going to be a zero one function and
it's going to be exactly new compliment
of basically s component so so you
actually don't need to evaluate it at
zero because the end result that you get
is a constant so the degrees match up so
so I said the oops so so the degree of
this thing is K the degree of this thing
is n minus K and I'm applying n partial
derivative operators so at the end I
don't need to apply I don't need to take
the variables to zero okay so by
definition this is the same as basically
new of s and I get what I wanted okay
now that the T's also work out so so for
that part you can just leave me worry
so so what's okay so why did we go
through all of this trouble the reason
we went through all this trouble was
that whenever you have a bunch of
partial operators apply to a POW mule
you can form a thing called the capacity
inequality so this is basically a
generalization of results proved by
Corbett's first and generalize in
various ways using using very clever
machinery so the thing that we rewrote
our partition function as which was
something of this form a bunch of
partial operators apply to a lock on a
farm you know you can you can lower
bound it by by a by an optimization
problem by the result of an optimization
problem okay so I gave a talk about this
in the previous workshop you can just go
see the details of that for the proof
but for now just just believe this so
this is a so this is basically based on
some intuitions about entropy and so on
but the end result is that to
approximate this this value of the of
the polymer form u times nu what you can
do is you can solve this optimization
problem and the result is is is an e to
the K approximation
so okay so so what is this optimization
problem this optimization problem
involves the palm use G mu and G new
compliment there is this funny p-value
that's outside this p-value you can
think of it as sort of like a marginal
okay so think of choosing a set s
according to two mu of s times nu of s
and this P would be the probability that
the elements I would be inside inside
the set s that easily so so for exactly
the for the exact margin of this gives
you an upper bound and and for any other
value of P this up to an e to the K
factor is zero okay so all right so so
we basically come up with a surrogate
for this partition function that we were
interested why is this surrogate good
why is this lock concave in the
variables T so so this is again a trick
that you can that basically Gurewitz
came up with what you can do is you can
absorb this P into the palm yells so
what I've done here is there is a P to
the P here you can you can basically
absorb this into the denominator and
that becomes
so so all I've done so far is just move
the the P to the P to the denominator
here but now since I'm doing that an
optimization over variables Y and Z I
can replace the variable Y by basically
so sorry I can let Y prime be Y over P
so if you do that then this becomes Y
Prime and here you get P times y Prime
nothing nothing crazy so far but then
for any fixed value of y this thing is
lock-on caving P Jim U of P times some
constant is lock-on caving P because
Jimmy who was lock-on caving P now when
you are doing basically now once you
once you do an infimum over over a bunch
of LOC concave functions you still get a
lock on K functions so you can also
solve this maximization problem on the
outside you can do the same trick for T
basically if you multiply the the
variables t1 up to TN to the right-hand
side of this you get
Yeji new compliment of Z over T times T
1 up to TN and this thing is is la
concave in terms of T is because this is
basically G new of
so for any fixed value of Z this thing
is locked concave in terms of T is and
once you do an infimum over a bunch of
LOC concave functions you still get
something that is la concave in terms of
T is so so the end result is a surrogate
for our partition function which is La
concave in terms of T is so it
everything works as long as new
complement is basically so as long as
both new and new complement give you
lock on K formula so we don't know so
for real stable of things this works
this flipping works but for LA concave
this doesn't work necessarily yeah but I
don't know a way currently so that's it
so okay so okay so I cheated a little
bit here so I assumed that that this new
function was a zero one valued function
which means that new was giving a
metroid constraint on our optimization
problem
so what Peter was saying was ok so forth
zero one valued functions we know that
this complementation operator preserves
lock concavity this complementation
operator also preserves la concavity
when when you have some stronger
condition called real stability but but
when you only knew that when when you
only know that nu is La concave this
doesn't necessarily hold so for non zero
one valued functions new compliment is
not necessarily la concave when you
start with a lock
so so for that case you could still
possibly try to do an optimization like
this and and hope that it gives you the
correct approximation but we don't know
so all right so this is all good for for
solving the determinant optimization
problem under a Metroid constraint but I
want to show you in the rest of the talk
another application of this so this is
Nashville for optimization I think in
one of the workshops we had to talk
about this so this is a this is an
optimization problem coming from
economics where you have a bunch of
items that you want to allocate to a set
of people so so these people there are n
persons they have utilities for these
items and their utilities are additive
meaning that when they get two items
they're get their total utility would be
the sum of the utilities for the
individual items so so there's a lot of
debate about how you should allocate
these items to people and there are
generally many criteria that people
study so one of them is for example
maximize the sum of the total total
utility so this is this is an easy
problem you just assign each item to the
person who appreciates it the most there
is also a variant where you want to
maximize the minimum utility of every
person that's trying to be like there
this is called the Santa Clause problem
and it's generally very difficult there
is also a middle ground called Nash
Social Welfare where you try to maximize
the geometric mean of the utilities
so this is like the the zero norm of the
utilities this is like the one known
sorry this is like negative infinity
norm this is like the the one norm this
is like a zero so so for this problem
let me just there's been a lot of work
on this problem but let me just mention
the the most recent one which gives you
an e to the 1 over f proximation
but but what i want to show you is the
worst approximation factor it's still
going to be a constant but it's gonna be
using this machinery so so first of all
the first time that you see this problem
the thing that you might try is to write
down basically a regular relaxation for
it so so you basically put down a
variable x IJ which which says whether
you allocated item j to person i and you
try to maximize the product of the sum
of the fractional utilities assigned to
terms so so there is only one constraint
that each item should be assigned a
total of one time and and you can
actually solve this relaxation because
the objective here is a polynomial
that's lock on k so when you take its
log becomes a concave function you can
optimize it and so on everything works
but the problem is that there are
actually examples where this relaxation
is very far off from the actual optimal
solution that you can possibly get so
think of basically an item which is very
highly valued so like let's say this
sweater is like loved by everybody so
what the fractional solution can do is
it can cheat and get like a third of the
sweater to this person a third to this
person and a third to this person and
now the product of the utilities would
be something non zero or very high but
but an actual solution would have to
allocate this Twitter to only one person
so let's say the rest of the items have
a utility of 0 the optimal solution
would be Z
whereas the fractional solution would be
none so so the thing that's causing this
problem is that we're not taking into
account the fact that each item has to
be allocated exactly once and what I
assume me
so even though this relaxation doesn't
work there is still hope to save it we
are still going to basically replace
this objective with a suitable surrogate
which is still la concave in terms of X
IJ s but we are going to make sure that
this lock concave surrogate that we put
in is always a good approximation to the
actual optimal solution so the way we
are going to do that is
is again by by running a randomized
algorithm and computing its expectation
and then and coming up with a surrogate
for that expectation okay so the
algorithm so assume that you've solved
this so forget about the fact that this
is this is a bad relaxation let's say
that you somebody has given you a bunch
of fractional values excited so one
thing that's very natural to try is to
to round this fractional solution to an
actual solution according to the X IJ s
and that means basically for each item J
allocated to the person I with
probability excited so for each item J
basically independently do this so if
the sweater was divided into thirds
between the people you just you just
come up with a random number between 1
and 3 and allocated the the sweater to
the person whose random named number K
okay so if you do this the there is a
there is an expected value that you get
at the end ok so the expected value that
you get at the end would be something
like the products of let's call them
capital X IJ J where X IJ is basically
the indicator variable of
whether you allocated item J to person I
okay so so so the reason this relaxation
is not good is that this expectation is
not equal to that you can't just take
the expectations inside and just replace
X IJ s by their expectation which is X
IJ
but what you can do is you can compute
this expectation so this expectation if
you so this product is over a person's
this song is over items so if you expand
out this product what you get is a sum
over basically all functions
the product of I equals 1 to N is equal
I
this is the this is still the same
expression I just expanded out the
product over the sum from each of these
sums I have to select one index J and
I'm just representing that choice by
Sigma Sigma I and now you can you can
now once you have a sum you can take the
expectation inside and and you can just
for each individual product see whether
or not what the expectation is so the
point is if Sigma is injective the
expectation you can take it inside and
the expectation would be
so the point is that if for each person
you you chose a different item then the
then the expected value that you you at
you took this assignment of items to or
to people is exactly the product of the
fractional values if however you
selected the same item for two different
people there is no way that that's the
assignment could be coming out of this
okay so the expectation is zero so now
what we're dealing with is very similar
to before the expectation of this this
algorithm this is basically a sum of
product of two partition functions sorry
a partition function of a product so now
if I define
time
so now I can define basically functions
over a ground set of pairs of items and
people so this is n times m and I'm
assigning I'm choosing just subsets of n
of these things this is taking this to
be isomorphic to basically
for an item
and I'm just looking at all subsets of
size and we're drive so so so what new
is going to do for me is going to it's
going to enforce this constraint that
the new of s a subset of people and
items is going to enforce this
constraint that in my set s I'm going to
look at only as I I'm going to only look
at sets where no item is allocated more
more than once to more than to more than
one people and but mu is going to do is
it's going to basically capture the
utilities plus the fact that the know no
person is allocated more than one ID so
to be makes it be the product of
entities
so Samui is going to basically give me
the coefficients of this formula if you
expand out this formula in this
objective function U is going to give me
the coefficients of this formula and mu
is going to enforce this additional
constraint that I should zero out the
terms corresponding to two allocations
which are giving an item to two people
so now basically the sum of the u.s.
scientists Udo's times the US this thing
is the expectation of my out right now
now now mu of s is a lock on K follow
because it's just a product of linear
things new of s is actually a Metroid
constraint right so you can you can
actually write it as an elementary
symmetric palm y'all so so think of
basically variable z IJ and then new of
basic service so you have zi j's would
be
so so if you expand out the elementary
symmetric polynomial of degree n out of
these sums
I'm just looking at basically products
of n terms out of these M terms that
corresponds to selecting n different
items out of the n different items and
when I expand out the product and from
each some I'm selecting basically an
assignment of an assignment of that item
to each person so this is also a lot
funky form so the same framework
basically applies and now you get a
surrogate for the partition function of
G of MU times nu and this surrogate
function is going to be also a concave
in terms of X I J's so you can do the
same maximization trick as before and
you can solve the optimization okay so
the degree of the palm oil's nu and mu
here are n so you get an e to the n
approximation and each of the n
approximation to the product is the same
as an e approximation to the geometric
mean
utilities are linear or habit well to
form this palm you'll I have to do this
right I mean if you're if you're dealing
with complicated functions like I don't
know some modular functions of utilities
and so on you don't even get palm wheels
so there are some extensions of this too
to nonlinear things there are there are
things like budget additive and PLC
utilities and so on where you still do
get some palm yells but let me not get
into that so I'm running out of time so
let me just finish up and mention some
open questions so okay so in the first
part I showed you that when we have
access to this view function and we are
doing an opting a discrete optimization
over this discrete function we can do a
random block to do sampling and to
compute the palm yo and using that
computation of the palm Y we can get a
to to do of K approximation but it's
very weird because we shouldn't need
access we shouldn't need basically
random walks or things of that sort and
you can do like local search algorithms
or things like that so all we know for
those is if you do for example local
search and view the the factor that you
are going to get is like K to the K when
you're doing the same at maximization
for example so it's it's an open
question whether whether you can get the
same approximation factor
deterministically so one other thing is
in all of this approximation when we
computed the surrogate for the palm
you'll form u times nu we ended up
approximating the maximum of this
function but we never actually showed
how to how to output a solution how to
out with a set Chiefs that guarantee
okay so so that's not a problem when
you're dealing with a single function mu
because then you can do method of
conditional expectations and actually
output a solution but form you times new
we don't know how to compute the
partition function exactly where or
enough well enough approximately so it's
still unclear whether we can output the
solution as well or not we can output
the max we can output an estimate of
what the maximum is but not the set not
the solutions so put it just a
cardinality constrain like a flight
software supposed to get it to the key
yeah
Automation suppose that really two
parameters one is the size that you're
choosing which is key yep but you also
make had this vectors in directly right
for which you looking at the determinant
right different right
so that dimension doesn't appear if so
so okay so if the dimension is higher
than the set that you're selecting in
this approximation factor you know you
don't see the dimension at all there are
generalizations for for when you are
selecting more vectors than the
dimension and then you have to define
what the volume means but in those cases
you can actually get much better results
using your results and I think
a guess we will reconvene in 10 minutes
[Applause]